technology has improved so much of our
lives
you can order something from fifty miles
away and have it delivered in 15 minutes
you can talk to someone across the globe
in five seconds but we have to ask
ourselves with so much that we gain what
is it that we're usually it's becoming
increasingly more likely that when you
visit a fast-food restaurant or a
grocery store that instead of a person
checking you out it'll be a machine self
serving and checkout kiosks are becoming
common and even replacing cashiers in
certain cases could this mean that this
profession as we know it might cease to
exist
with the ease of online booking the
necessity for a travel agent has all but
disappeared now that you can get all the
news you want at just the touch of a
finger why would you need a newspaper
but what does that say about the
paperboy or a book publishing house or
even the printing press it wasn't so
long ago that you could walk into any
one of your neighborhood drugstores and
find somewhere to process thirty
five-millimeter fell but with the rise
of digital photography it's become
increasingly harder to find
self-driving cars are expected to work
without the necessity of a driver
stellar motors and left are reportedly
joining forces and will work on building
a network of self-driving cars GM will
reportedly invest 500 million and left
with the recent advent of self-driving
cars what does that say about uber lyft
or even taxi drivers does that mean
they'll become obsolete as well